Disney you okay you can't it isn't you
you know looking so good you've been
vomiting up some concerning stuff you
know the stuff that you had you know in
your body and it's coming up not so good
you know if you're Mary Poppins returns
and you kept a Marvel and your um your
Aladdin that's uh right on the the high
point of your beauty and the bees remake
and your Jungle Book remake and your
Sleeping Beauty remake and Dumbo remake
and get Lion King coming up too and I'm
sure Jungle Book 2 and Maleficent too
it's uh but at least Pixar's doing a
good job with your Toy Story 4 you don't
this was bad that's what's really bad I
can't even believe I'm saying this but
um if you thought the Beauty and the
Beast remake was bad this technically is
worse it didn't anger me as much because
because I love the original Beauty and
the Beast I really like Aladdin uh when
I was a kid I it was my favorite anime
Disney movie I absolutely loved it and
when I got older I was like okay I um I
really like this guy there's a lot to
appreciate a lot to enjoy this is
incredible energy and it looks amazing
you know but it's a little more the
characters a kind of Gen X ish and some
of the jokes they're like add to the
jokes are pretty good but it it felt
like you think who I have the substance
of something like Fantasia or Beauty and
the Beast or Dumbo or something like
that I like a lot of stuff I look back
I'm like okay like that had weight to it
these movies had weight where Aladdin is
a ton of fun and really cool and super
funny you know but I thought there's
there's not much weight to it which is
fine you need that you need to mix it up
uh but I still I love
back then and I love now the spectacle
of it it seemed like from Little Mermaid
on a pride to to Lion King
they kept upping the spectacle with
their animated films and and a lad I
mean that's the one before Lion King I
mean before like the big spectacle opus
soso Aladdin looks great and it has this
incredible momentum and of course this
wonderful humor and the colors are just
amazing I mean it's just one of those
Wow anime of films um and this one is
not it just oh alright so let me say the
positives I think there's two the
orchestrating the orchestration of the
songs is actually in my opinion better
and that's saying something because the
orchestrations of the original Latin
songs are really friggin great I may
because I saw it on IMAX and and 3d and
the sound is really great but like these
songs like I mean the that this thing's
kinda hitting this I mean it's not
Beauty and the Beast remake bad don't
worry but you know they're kinda hit
missed but the the orchestration like
like just sounded great so so that's
really saying something cuz the First's
Aladdin had great orchestrations um
gasps gotta be something else
um I think that's it can't think of
anything else that's better than the
animated one uh oh you know what and the
woman who played jasmine uh I thought
she did a really good job like to me
this is someone that's like even though
she's not written that well it big shock
nobody's written that well but uh she
had like I don't know just this passion
to her performance and she had this
charm and she looked wonderful and she
had this good enough singing voice you
could tell they had to auto-tune it but
like getting everybody's auto-tune the
do they got to play Aladdin looks like
almost exactly like a man sounds
exactly like I'm like it's kind of eerie
need a little bit more a little bit more
charm in there I like I don't know there
there should then a ship in a few more
takes I like it take two or is something
I like try it like this try it a little
bit more jokey try it yeah let's talk
about the jokes oh my gawd oh this
movies not funny it's just not funny and
and like the humor is just I guess it's
supposed to be like awkward humor I
guess like there's a running joke about
Jam like that's it they're like what
would you bring me Prince Ali I brought
you jams so many jams and they just keep
bringing it up that he brought jams get
it
I don't jams Will Smith is just dying
he's just dying in this role and I can't
okay here's the thing
Will Smith is a charming dude he's just
the smooth awesome guy but he's smooth
and awesome ways with people when he has
to be on his own and not just on his own
but he has to like be in this weird CG
body that does it the kind of moves like
the Casper CGI ghost from the movie
Casper and light like but for how they
move whether they're talking right here
then suddenly right here and their
burger here they're always moving a
little wonky and they're just starting
close up for no reason it's like all
that just throughout most of it and yeah
like there's just a million scenes where
he's just kind of saying stuff or you're
kinda like is that a joke well what was
that was that funny saying that the only
top of my head the only joke I could
think that legit worked was I think
Jafar also horribly cast actually the
casting and this isn't like awful awful
but but your far is just like just pick
a random guy from the street no presence
whatsoever but he did have this one
lion-o I
is that he has like the only backstory
to give him at all it's a he used to be
a thief too which is kind of like all
right that's kind of cool
and he tells the laddies as you know you
steal an apple you're a thief you steal
Kingdom you're a statesman I'm like oh
good that's a good line actually I think
like just any other positives man I mean
it's like I like that when he turns into
a prince they say the genie powers
include that nobody can recognize you
it's like okay that explains that cuz
that's something in the original made
note says he has a hat who is he you
know it's like the Clark Kent glasses
you know suddenly he's somebody else but
yeah a lot of it is just like the Beauty
and the Beast remake where they just
move some things around for seemingly no
reason like well now this happens at
this scene and now before you even know
jasmine is a princess she's you know on
the street you know looking for food and
Aladdin comes and stops her hand from
getting chopped off whatever it's like
that they just switch around like that
happens before you know she's the
princess in the palace and it's like
that's so what and you know they add one
or two little things which is like kind
of seems pointless and whenever they get
to a line that said from the movie you
know like do you trust me or something
like that like a lot of these famous
lines all you're thinking is man that
had that had more of an impact when I
saw it the first time because there is
just you even feel like they're saying
these lines and doing these things just
because well it was in the first one the
the climax where the giant snake
remember like he's got these knives
flying around it's a giant hourglass and
the genies kind of cheering him on and
then like he's gotta jump out and the
boo is turned into this little toy the
genie turns out boo into a toy at one
point like he's the villain almost in
the middle of this song and and the
carpet unravels like it's all it's all
red it's dark and lightning and it is
crazy this one has a big parent spoiler
that's
that's the climax yeah and you get you
know giant snake giant parrot upgrade
what are you doing dis video what are
you doing oh boy um yeah that they try
to add they add an additional song it's
it's kind of forgettable it's kind of
like the girl power song I guess and
it's it's you cut it from the movie and
not miss that thing they try to play up
you know they try to give Jasmine I
guess a little bit more of a character
which I mean like I feel like the
original was fine but again just changed
something God do you know I'll take it
and they have this whole thing I won't
be silent I won't be silent like that's
kind of the song and you know and she
sings that you have a hint of it earlier
and then she sings a big time like in
later in the film and it's all I could
think of is that you know following this
scene she uses diplomacy to kind of make
a scene better she doesn't really save
the day or anything
uh but it's again it's the I won't be
sad I won't be silent and cool she you
know there's actually a little talk
about like politics about how to rule
which I'm kind of okay with because like
you think like Princess Diaries like no
you didn't know how to walk like it
brings it's an old a fan like in France
and it's like how about rolling a
goddamn Kingdom like they they do talk
about that a little bit of and I'm
Gallic alright cool like that
that's okay um and I feel like they some
of the talks I'm like why are we talking
about this like about invading other
kingdoms and stuff but I mean there is a
/ me I'm just like just because I never
see that in like Disney films you know
when it's a princess you wear pretty
clothes or you want more I don't want be
told what to do it so what do you want
to do you know it's like I like this is
my that you like no you you you want
power you want to control it take some
responsibility and being a leader but
not like a leader of your friends like
like a leader of a kingdom you know like
and it isn't just like just be nice to
commoners you know
it's like--there's I kind of dig that a
little bit even though like they don't
they don't do a ton with it but they tap
I just enough where I'm kind of like
alright you know but that's more just
because I don't see it like in Disney
films like it's it's not interesting
like they don't make it that much fun or
cool or anything um yeah yeah anything
else like that's actually good oh you
know what I'll give us some credit or
give us some cred uh the friend like me
song is actually okay it's one of the
few moments where there's some really
cool visuals they have some fun with the
camera and the collars and stuff like
that to a point where when it was
wrapping up Chicago band was wrapping up
I was like oh I was actually kind of
getting into this you know so uh and
again the orchestrations were good the
only song that's just a complete bomb
like wow did that do nothing it's like
my favorite song in Aladdin is Prince
Ali and you probably seen clips of it on
YouTube it's like one of the little
previews they had it does not get any
better after that's that's like the one
scene where you can okay so in the
credits they have they have a little
dance number of just everybody dancing
it's really well put together and I
think it's done like in one shot and
everything and it's like that was really
cool cuz that's all I think they speed
it up sometimes or something like that
but like it's still these people really
they're doing this dance number it looks
like the guy who plays Aladdin there's a
good dance actually the one played
jasmine I saw right I mean looks like a
good dancer let's see CG their head on
there or something like that which if so
that's good CG artists but if somebody
it's good to answer there's some good to
answers in this whoever they are whether
it's really the people or their CG or
whatever but there are good dancers and
like the Prince Ali song is where like
you can do that you can just have fun
with these people coming out I mean make
it like Portobello Road from Bedknobs
and Broomsticks just like this
unbelievable thing but it's just Will
Smith and Badu playing Aladdin just
standing there going
I like that you like Will Smith's like
this and Latins like this it's like
that's it
it's like you've done so much with that
well why you wait for the credits to
pull out the big dance sequence so yeah
it's another unfortunate situations
where a lot of is kept the same unless
they switch it around the stuff they add
like I don't remember being awful or
anything like it but but it's not much I
mean they just do not add that much and
because it just feels so much like what
we have to just hit these notes uh it
feels like there's no momentum to it
like scenes just kind of they either
drag on forever or they're way too quick
and you never feel like any of the
emotion you're supposed to feel free
scare icterus or any of the comedy like
it just so drags it just feels like it
goes on forever and I mean granted I
didn't see this with I saw pretty late
at night I mean so the crowd was you
know I mean there's probably something
like 20 30 people in there or something
like that as some of them were kids and
it was just dead silent I don't know how
this is gonna play for kids I mean it
still will Smith blue you know and he's
moving like the caspere characters like
this sometimes and that could get going
so I don't know um I I mean it my guess
would be kids really like Will Smith
still so I mean like it did my play okay
for kids but yeah my guess is just a lot
of kids are gonna be like yeah can we
just put on the cartoon again the
cartoon it's such life such energy I
mean it was another one of those movies
where it just feels like it leaps off
the screen this one just feels like it's
draining the life from you I mean it's
just so odd in how and just how lifeless
it feels I'm even though like you know
sometimes there are some nice visuals
and some nice colors and stuff like that
but it just feels just so lifeless um
and yeah it's I'm sorry like I feel
drained watching this movie I just feel
like I just watched
like it's not a whole bunch of nothing
and that oh I just looked at a blank
screen but it's like it had just enough
little splash of color you know
occasionally like a nice sounding song
and then just a whole bunch of nothing
so it's it's like what do you say about
that well here's some nothing and
occasional Keller occasional song
actually I guess I just said it um I
feel like this movie made me dumb I'll
say this as well
the we're Beauty and the Beast legit
made me like angry mad like oh my god
this is just so infuriating this is kind
of so bad it's funny some of the
comedians are just so painful and you
can tell they're just trying to
improvise a little bit or maybe like
we're trying to make what was written
here funny and it's just not working and
they're just so trying to make it work
and it's just not you know and I feel
like I feel like a lot of that's Gabby
and maybe it's not the direction
although I mean it was a Guy Ritchie he
directed a good film and a half that
that's about the extension I can't give
him I liked I liked locks Jackman Lock
Stock and Two Smoking Barrels and then
snatch was just another one of those
without the charm but but but I like
lock stock so much that it's like well
snatch I give a little bit of a basket
because I like the first one Sam I just
like that style and then like he's never
done anything else good as far as I know
unless I'm missing something but every
other movie that's like come out
afterwards I mean everyone was just meh
yeah that's like no that was terrible oh
no no Sherlock Holmes that was good I
forgot about that he did he do good
Sherlock Holmes okay that's uh that's
two and a half okay give him great for
that
um maybe I'm missing another one - but
he's not someone that's like on my radar
of like ooh a Guy Ritchie film you know
kind of thing um but yeah I just feel
like if they could have okay you never
know what the schedules on these movies
I mean if they just have more time to
create more charisma with the people and
the characters but I mean but they're
not
give him much to work with either I mean
these are just very obvious bland lines
when they're not just taking it from the
first film and the stuff that's added is
very generic stuff that's added I mean
like you know okay well well Jasmine's
gonna stand up for herself i we haven't
seen that that's her character you know
but but again they're like I felt like
that actress kind of brought a little
something to it like she made it almost
charming like almost work where I'm like
okay I want to see her in something else
you know even I play Aladdin why like he
had a good look and he had like a good
voice a he could if that's really him
dance and everything like he can move I
I mean like you can see a career for
this too but yeah it's like you just
need you need someone to steer you in a
better direction you need to are better
right or just something you just you
need love all you need is love this just
feels like a paycheck this just feels
like oh well these worked Beauty and the
Beast was a hit you know Mary Poppins
returns did good and I mean we didn't
have to put much new into that just do
it again
paycheck you know but where were these
kind of movies i unders you know I can
understand one or two of these just like
okay get that out so we can fund these
you know like these cool things that
Disney used to make like I just feel
like they're not making those anymore
like I I mean I guess they still have
Marvel I mean that it like an end game
was good but like I said even you know
Captain Marvel sure wasn't that great
and and now they have Fox I mean maybe
they can do something with that but yes
Star Wars now I'm just getting tired of
- I mean so I don't know um
they better whip something out that
that's pretty cool cuz I feel like I'm
like a Disney always I feel like they
hit that slump for a while and like they
always have even in the 60s and 50s like
you know like there's always kind of a
slump they start to hear where they'll
recycle a lot of stuff or they'll just
kind of you know exploit what's popular
at the time you know like if you look at
some of the
teen films from like the 50s and 60s
late like there's some good ones don't
get me wrong but there's some crap too
and I just feel like man we're just
we're coming up on that slump again I
just hope they can get some just good
imaginative stuff again like fresh stuff
yeah I mean the freshest thing they got
coming out is frozen too and that's
still a sequel you know I mean I don't
know and I know technically everything
is always based on like a fairy tale and
stuff like that or famous books and such
but I don't know they gave it a new spin
you know like Snow White I mean like
everyone knew the story of Snow White
but when you talk about the Disney Snow
White you know what they're talking
about you know the look of it you know
the characters you know the names you
know the style you know the environment
where I mean if you were to say Aladdin
well yeah the animated one no the remake
um well Will Smith right like that's
probably all people are gonna say about
it just Will Smith was in it I know that
so yeah I don't know I'm missing that
Disney that can stand out you know it's
just it's all blurring together now Star
Wars is blurring together you know
Marvel had endgame so it's like that's
cool like that was a that was kind of
like a big stuff even though I don't
love all of it or anything I'm still
like that but that's a step but that's
kind of a risk they they they did some
interesting creative things with that
where this just feels like I don't know
I I hope I can get things like just the
creative juices going again cuz man if
there's just more of these like uh I I
just want that uniqueness back I want
that freshness bag and I just feel like
I'm not getting there right now at least
not from their movies and maybe from
their event made me from the theme parks
are still doing giving me a run of TV
shows here star versus the force of evil
is very good you know so like maybe I
got to go there but yeah the movies
recently man I have not been hitting out
of the park for me so hopefully more
stuff will be coming I'm sorry it's
turned more into like a Disney brand
Aladdin ran but that's what this movie
does it's just we're dog matters
I can't take it anymore with these
Disney reboots so um yeah that's uh if
you have little kids and they want to
see if they see the trailer and they
want to see it it's it's fine I mean I
guess like they can watch it and just be
like okay I my assumptions are gonna
kind of a blank face most of it but like
they will be quiet
exactly it's a totally decent shut up
move just to place your kids in front as
I okay I just I need a break
kids watch this you know but if you're
looking for something to like really
like enchant and delight and awaken the
imagination a man I I did not see that
here and then maybe some other people
will some other kids but I I missed all
of that so yeah and like I said I hate
viewing the beast
the reboot more because I really loved
that movie but because also going in I
think everybody knows this is just kind
of gonna suck like only the people that
saw the trailers they went ooh it's like
it's more of that but like most of the
people I've seen are just like man it
looks stupid this feels like the year of
movies that don't feel real you got
Aladdin get Dora the Explorer
you got Sonic the Hedgehog toy story for
pork you realize he's a chewy like does
that just feel like that like it just
feels like these aren't real movies that
were the Emperors back in Star Wars so I
don't know it didn't win me over I
didn't see anything new to it that was
exciting
um it just seemed like rehash a very
boring rehash so that's my take again if
you saw the trailer like that might like
this looks like this looks cute this
looks fun
you'll probably get that you'll get the
trailer it really is like everyone
that's at all-that trailer looks so
stupid and nothing will smith looks you
know ugly and weird and stuff like that
I mean that's what you're gonna think of
the movie if you look at your like oh
it's turn my brain off just go have fun
I know that song fair enough
what like there's crap I see you where
I'm just like I kind of want to do that
too but yeah this wasn't the one for me
so um that's about it I'll see you at
the next awful tis me reboot or maybe
you'll be good it'll be awful bye
you